[Music]
foreign
there's no time
[Music]
the time is thirteen o'clock
hey everybody it's friday night here we
are yeah we had a little bit of
technical difficulties with the dab
laser
figure we just forgot how to turn it off
yeah it's like you could have just given
me the remote and i would have turned it
off
instead of you being over there for five
minutes a bunch of [ __ ] on me pushing
the problem
i don't [ __ ] blame it she's gonna
blame me well i think like i found it
earlier on the floor so i think pookie
was in here like knocking [ __ ] off of
she was in here like [ __ ] around yeah
at the last minute i looked back there
and says man are lasers on
get a sound check is everybody um happy
with the sound yeah because you know how
paranoid i am about this [ __ ]
microphone doing weird paranormal [ __ ]
when i'm not like looking
and decides to change the setting nobody
says did tom touch the laser yeah he did
[Laughter]
okay um so i guess there's no problem
with the audio today is gonna be
db cooper which is pretty good so i'm i
got my airborne ranger
[ __ ] equipment on my [ __ ] patrol
cap and everything
in solidarity for a plane jumper outer
yeah
yeah plain jumper router i'm pretty sure
that he jumped
airborne ranger style
but uh what have we got going jenny is
there any shoutouts or anything we have
to do it's
looks like everybody's here yeah there
is um you know i think that i tried to
get
to disseminate the information as widely
as possible
but uh in case you didn't notice we are
going to start doing the
main episodes the live streams on friday
nights now at 6 00 pm
what the hell don't worry about oh my
god what is he doing over there
zach says the mic sounds a tad different
but i can't say why i had to turn down
the gain because it was like
recording me really loud so i don't know
i don't know what it's doing it's
like i said the settings just keep
changing oh you know what that volume is
off below right there
no it's fine that's it that's it's fine
that's fine oh you know what
i just realized something like showing
one mic now before we were having all
those problems it was showing too wasn't
it
it was actually showing three like i
said that's what i was like it was
adding microphones
willy-nilly yeah what's the bottom one
that says turned off that's webcam
because the webcam also has a microphone
but obviously i don't want that
microphone recording also so that one is
on
and look this is what it's doing this is
going to come down a little bit because
it's
i had that it was going up into the red
i had that done exactly the way it was
supposed to be
okay it shouldn't be buzzing out now you
you messed it up
i'm messing [ __ ] up yeah just saying i'm
missing don't touch anything
i had all the settings done exactly the
way they were supposed to be done that
[ __ ] went up into the red i saw it and
now it's fine
okay it's fine just don't yell it'll be
fine okay i'm gonna
just be quiet then
me and amanda smith are already drunk oh
man it's like
uh we just you know we just started we
we don't drink before the show
no i'm not drunk here got soaps in there
zach's here badgers in
ilsa is in there amanda b's nest
everybody's in here yeah everybody's
there everybody's in here [ __ ]
badgers in there
tammy t hasn't showed up yet
should be here probably yeah i felt like
some people like i said i made it like a
little graphic and i put it on facebook
and
instagram and everything but you know
we're going to start moving the shows to
friday nights at 6 p.m
uh just so we can have saturdays off
cause we want to go out on saturday
nights
also um i think i mentioned to you that
my witching hour show
i'm going to discontinue that it's still
it's going to go through the end of
march like i already have the next three
episodes already done
like in the can but after that starting
april 1st
i'm going to start doing some uh
horror movie reviews and posting like
recording them and then posting them
maybe thursdays
and or saturdays um because just i have
such a huge backlog of horror movies
people keep recommending them to me like
old ones and new ones and [ __ ]
and it's you know i put ones in the
polls but only we
you know we only get to do one a week
then review one a week so i was just
kind of like i really need to work
through this backlog
so i guess i'll just do them like i do
my book reviews and you know so i'll
just do
like some movie reviews if it's if it's
a movie that i think you don't really
give a [ __ ] about or you don't really
oh just you want to watch yeah yeah
because like i said i was uh
you know i'll just do it like the book
reviews it's easier
yeah mango said yesterday's witching
hour is great i love mr james yeah he's
probably one of my favorite ones to do
um
i really like ef benson as well i think
um
the next one i can't remember what the
next one is i'm doing some uh
i'm doing one by wilkie collins i think
but that might be a couple
weeks ahead because like i said i got i
got all the ones for march done already
i finished him up today i see you karen
tom always skips me she's insulted
but yeah so hopefully this uh new time
kind of works for everybody
i know it's not gonna work for everybody
but oh well oh well what are you gonna
do you can't make everybody happy
no matter what day you pick it's
somebody it's not gonna work out for
somebody
yeah and we're still gonna do we might
change [ __ ] around
but we'll see yeah and i mean we're
still gonna do the live matinees
like on sunday monday tuesday we're
still gonna do the party stream
wednesday we're gonna do all that stuff
still it's just a couple things that are
changing
so you know nothing bad you gotta have a
saturday yeah doing this [ __ ] for over a
year
like this yeah and as i said um you know
hopefully me adding some more
movie reviews will kind of make up for
it if you can't catch the [ __ ] live on
fridays because i know a couple people
were like meh
you know i'm kind of crying about it but
uh you know
brad says just got off work yeah for 13
o'clock see and just that's what i
figured that's why i pushed it back to
six o'clock
so i figured people would be getting
home they'd be wanting to watch the
stuff
you know that's that's all it is all
right so
uh i also have a couple of shout outs
this week i already talked about the new
show schedules
um had a generous donation
by someone named alan that was a paypal
donation so thank you alan thank you
very much
also got a new patron jason w
a very generous patron thank you very
much also holly who was one of our
patrons before and then had to leave for
a little while and then she came back
uh and increased her support a lot so
thank you very much holly thanks
everybody
your support is always greatly
appreciated sas is in the house all the
way from down under out in the outback
i come from a land and under it i
imagine
probably sick of hearing that [ __ ] yeah
because every time they introduce
themselves
and they're just probably like wow yeah
that in outback steakhouse commercials
just kind of like for a very long time
in the night in the 90s and 2000s every
time i told people what my name was
everybody would do a forrest gump
impression why
because he he's like jenny oh okay
oh my god i've only seen that movie once
and i had the [ __ ] manager where i
worked still doing that like in 2013
i'm like bro jesus christ that's a
terrible movie
yeah i couldn't stand that i felt like
it was okay like i
i kind of enjoyed it at the time like
when it came out but then when i saw it
again i'm like oh my god this actually
sucks what the [ __ ]
but um when i told the boomer thing yeah
i guess i think you had to be a boomer
to really kind of understand that
it was kind of like the edification of
mediocrity
if you were just dull and mediocre then
you were great that's what that movie
meant
well yeah you just kind of like fall ass
backwards into awesomeness
yeah like boomers
maybe that's why they're related so
you're like upwards
yeah and plus like i said i i get i'm
not like offended or anything but when
people
um you know say that to me like and
call me jenny like in the forest gump
voice i'm like so
you're comparing me to a woman who they
totally slut-shamed through the whole
thing and then she dies of aids
awesome you know what i mean they made
her look like a horrible horrible person
it was just i don't know just i hate
that movie so much
like i said i don't think it bothered me
at the time but what i saw the second
time i was just kind of like oh god what
the actual [ __ ]
um but yeah what i told peop back in the
80s when i told people my name was jenny
they asked me if my phone number was
eight six seven five three or nine yeah
so i got that a lot too
but uh yeah then it was the forrest gump
thing i don't even how do we even start
talking about that i don't know
um oh oh because of the uh because of
the uh
down under thing yeah yeah so i i
imagine every time you tell somebody
you're from australia they ask you about
vegemite sandwiches
i saw i saw pictures of it in a jar i
actually saw that in the damn group it
doesn't look good you can buy it and buy
it in the import section yeah yeah
that didn't look good it's not real
funky
i was tempted it's just vegetable spread
right
yeah kinda it's kind of it's not as
gross as it sounds but
it is kind of like earthy so i can see
why people might not
like it i might like that [ __ ] you
probably would
yeah it's probably just like hummus yeah
i don't know we were talking it's funny
because we were talking about refried
beans earlier
and i was saying that you know for the
cookbook i said god it's like
it's [ __ ] wicked hard to get a good
picture
of refried beans because every picture
of it looks like [ __ ] a dirty diaper
but it's deceptive though because that
[ __ ] is like really really good it's
just not real photogenic
is all and uh you know maybe some foods
have that i mean when i was growing up i
would not eat refried beans because i
just thought they looked too [ __ ]
gross
they were near little did i know
vegemite is a [ __ ] acquired taste but
it's awesome
this one lasts a lifetime because you
only need a little bit
it's kind of like you know every every
english-speaking country has their crazy
thing in a [ __ ] jar and it turns out
like
americans and peanut butter that's like
a crazy thing in england they don't like
it
although i saw a video of an american
guy eating british
peanut butter and he just he hated it
he's like god this is some shitty peanut
butter
like that's not normal he goes no that's
not [ __ ] peanut butter it's garbage
he said it was super super sweet and it
the texture was all wrong
and what was funny is it was like a
normal brand it's just
i guess that's what they're used to over
there what they maybe that's why they
hate it
yeah because they they don't make it
right they don't make it right or they
or they think they're making it they
think we make it and it's
not that's what he said i mean i've
never had anything from
mango says we love peanut butter here
well i do
yeah i guess i i don't know my
ex-husband was british and he didn't
like it at first but then like when he
started eating he's like oh this is
actually good i was like yeah so
i don't think they really know what to
do with it
buttered toast with jelly on one side
and peanut butter on the other you eat
like that you got to toast that [ __ ] on
raw bread no
no and really you want cheap bread like
wonder bread
i mean you got to toast it you need that
like you need it to be like it's good on
any
any kind of bread but there's something
about it just being on a regular basis
white bread it's just
i don't know toasted it's what you can
eat it but
yeah i mean i see it in my little
sandwiches it's great on her
it's great on vanilla ice cream yeah
well
and honestly like they make peanut sauce
and
you know in thai food and that's that
shit's good on everything man
yeah holy crap that's kind of different
though it is not
much it still tastes very peanut buttery
there's fish oil in it and stuff
yeah but yeah it like i said it doesn't
taste that different
and like you said if you melt peanut
butter and like pour it over vanilla ice
cream that's really really good too
yeah michael schaefer said peanut butter
is best with a spoon right out of the
jar
i've done that a few times if you you
know thank you zack
almond butter is earthy as [ __ ] and i
love that [ __ ] yeah
i love almond butter too and like i said
before cashew butter is awesome speaking
of food the um
the cookbook is uh making making good
strides yeah i actually
was able to set aside a few hours today
to work on that and hopefully
tomorrow i can work on it pretty much
all day if nothing else comes up
but it says the dunkin donuts is selling
avocado toast
now that's it so good avocado toast it
is yeah
just uh avocados are delicious
california style guacamole man i think
it's good on anything too
yeah yeah yeah amanda says to me peanut
butter and tahini paste
taste nearly the same they're they are
they're similar
tahini is the same idea it's just that
it's uh sesame seeds yeah
so yeah or sunflower seeds yeah wait
isn't it
i thought it was sesame seeds but i
could be totally wrong about that i
can't remember
chad says peanut butter and jelly on
eggo waffles yep
i used to eat i used to put ice cream in
between two eggo waffles as well
yep like when i was a little kid you
toast them and then the ice cream would
get all kind of melty in the middle
you want the peanut butter slightly
melted just a little bit that's why you
want the bread toasted it's got to be
hot
matter of fact you can put the peanut
butter and jelly in the toast and have
it butter to put it back in the pan and
some more butter
to get it to melt a little bit more so
it's just kind of like
like like a crispy thing that kind of
oozes out the side
salty peanuts and sweet jelly all kind
of jam me
call you guys you guys call it jab we
call it jam more jelly although there's
a difference
there is a difference yeah jelly is not
jello there's a difference
yeah in the uk if you say jelly that's
they're talking about yellow yeah
so we're talking about jam yeah
jam and peanut
that was susan outer wasn't it yeah
stopped the insanity
yeah he edited together like her going
jams jams it was really funny
you have to see it you kind of had to be
there all right so
um looks like everybody's in here yeah
it looks like it show
that's what i was just gonna think dj
maniac says when i was a kid i thought
there was only one ego in the box
because of the [ __ ] commercials
because then the but didn't the eggo
like pop out of the box
right like it was a toaster the eggo
commercials like from when i was a kid i
think that's what they had
you thought there was only one in there
how many was in there eight i think it
was eight
man i love eggo waffles just like 11 on
stranger things
that was one of my favorite things and
like i said you could do everything with
it you could toast it you put ice cream
in there you could make a sandwich out
of it
go nuts jen jen's called it right
jam has got pieces of fruit in it for
america
jelly doesn't it's just juice it's easy
to make
pectin you could take apple juice or
grape juice and turn that into jelly
it's good yeah it's just juice pectin
and sugar yeah right
i think that's all good boil it up and
then you just refrigerate it and bean
there it is
yeah you put it in any jar and make your
own i made it in seventh grade homemade
to it
yeah nothing to it and a seventh grade
home equity could make it
it's easy if you've got pieces of fruit
you can put that in there too but
you know the real you know country
version of that [ __ ] you know what i
mean when you're
you know looking poor it's just gonna be
grape juice
grape juice or apple juice you're gonna
make jelly with that and we used to make
something man i didn't put that
in i didn't put that in the uh well it's
not done yet you can still put it we
should
put that in the damn cookbook what this
[ __ ] is
this [ __ ] is mississippi as [ __ ] it's
called apple butter
oh yeah yeah butter yeah i'm gonna write
that down all right yeah they might want
some of that in australia and in england
it's like it's like a jam
but it's made out of apple it's not
applesauce but it is a jam that is apple
and kind of uh
i don't want to say it's a slightly
gritty it's like it's pureed apple
and you spread it on butter it's it's
delicious it's delicious
yeah it's easy to make apple butter you
put it on like
puttered toast you put that on there
you're eating good on a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich
i might have to put it on the same page
as peanut butter and jelly if i have
room
yeah otherwise
southern [ __ ] kind of like um think of
it as kind of like
applesauce but it's it's slightly it's
slightly cured
like you know like a jam would be i
guess yeah
slightly yeah it's good
yeah michael's not real powerful it's
got kind of a smooth
sweet apple flavor
and it's it was a butter substitute
probably came out damn depression
well yeah because you had apples grown
in the back of your backyard and stuff
so you just turned that into something
that was like a substitute for
butter back in the depression you
remember the thing that they use it and
you can still make it nowadays uh
mock apple pie like you couldn't get you
couldn't when you couldn't get apples
and [ __ ] like that you made them with
[ __ ]
ritz crackers and something else
and you put it all together i can't
remember how you make it but there's
actually no apples in it
but it tastes just like apple pie it's
the craziest [ __ ] i've ever had
yeah look it up like one of these it's
called mock apple pie that's actually
crackers
it's crackers and a couple other things
it's like super super cheap to make it's
i think you have to use ritz crackers
some kind of like buttery
cracker and i can't remember what else
is in there maybe some sugar or some
other [ __ ] like that but there's no
actual apples in it but for some reason
i don't know how it tastes like an apple
pie
i don't think i would make that how did
you get your hands on that well that was
from it was one of those
depression era recipes where like if you
couldn't get fresh fruit like to make an
apple pie with
um that was like a cheap way of making
it
and it tasted just like apple pie i but
i don't know how
because because none of the ingredients
like seem like they would taste anything
like apples
there's no fruit in it no it's super
weird
yeah it's like pretty famous for that
exact reason because
i just i don't know it's it's mysterious
super high in carbohydrate but when
you're starving it doesn't matter
well yeah they're just like any any
calories are good yeah
they didn't have to worry about dieting
about us all getting fat like nowadays
michael she says they make apple butter
up north too yeah yeah
okay and uh amanda says apple butter
makes uh
great barbecue sauce yeah it would that
would be a good battle probably so
michael shafer says hell a bag of apples
are probably cheaper than a box of ritz
crackers
yeah nowadays probably yes apple jam and
apple butter
are two different things they're used to
be used the same way
it's more kind of like apple sauce but
it's thicker
and sweeter like a giant like a jelly
yeah
i remember people making it but i don't
remember how to make it i'd have to go
back and look and it's
might have a little bit of cinnamon in
it
it's good there's a bunch of different
ways to do it yeah trevor's saying that
the uh mock apple pie the other
ingredients other than ritz crackers
were cream of tartar and cinnamon
okay and it somehow tastes like apples
that's really bad for you i don't know
how no nutritional value
well no but like i said if you want an
apple pie you can't get no apples that's
like
yeah that's like the next best thing all
right so
are we done talking about food now yeah
all right yeah
we got a bunch of people in there
waiting so okay so we got a lot of
a lot of stuff to get to with this who
would have thought that this case would
be so kind of
complicated i think it's only
complicated because there were so many
suspects and they never found the dude
and they never found out who the dude
was
db cooper was a classic case that's
never been solved
we're going to tell you we're not going
to solve it it's not going to be soft
this is a classic [ __ ] case yeah we
had a great conversation talking about
dv cooper you could talk about db
cooper all day long the thing that's
fascinating about this one is that there
are so many suspects
and every single one of them could
totally be him
i mean you know what i mean it's who
knew that there were so many people that
looked like that dude and had the
experience that they think and had like
some weird [ __ ] in his life they were
like oh yeah that guy could totally be
him
it's [ __ ] crazy hold on tammy came
out said
apple butter is just take some damn
applesauce with cloves and cinnamon
and cook it forever and that's yeah
that's you're right that's what it is
it makes the best jam so who's who's
this douche here that i'm going to block
what's he do what do you think
oh i don't know he's i saw some stupid
shitty within uh earlier wasting your
time talking about oh yeah
yeah well he was saying some stupid [ __ ]
earlier about the intro and everything
so i'm just like whatever i do
um so anyway i don't know who that is
yes i mean it's just some rando um all
right so
yeah but i you know i watched a bunch of
stuff about this
and it's weird because i was telling him
before we started recording the show i
was kind of like
for a long time i'm going to say and i'm
still kind of leaning in this direction
i think that the dude probably didn't
make it um
[Music]
but there's still a little part of me
that thinks maybe he might have
i don't know there was a lot of factors
against him though
um but then some of the [ __ ] they found
out later i was like oh it's possible he
could have survived but
i don't know i don't know i i lean more
toward he probably didn't make it
you know what i'm saying i don't think
he made it i'm gonna get to it
what's up no i was just laughing i
thought you were going to say something
else but then you just kind of well no
it's a little too early for me to give
my verdict
but uh i don't think the dude made it
yeah i'm i'm pretty sure he didn't but
like i said it's it's fun to talk about
the possibilities
there's some reasons why i don't think
he made it but let's talk about the case
first
so uh in case you're completely
unfamiliar with this case which i don't
know
how you would be because i feel like
everybody's pretty familiar with this
but maybe if you're in another country
you don't know because this is kind of
like
in the u.s uh in the u.s at least this
is kind of one of the most
easily one of the most famous heists one
of the most famous uh disappearances
for a long time i think it was kind of
the fbi's
uh only unsolved air piracy
uh case as far as i can recall
oh they're they're they're in the
comments section going
already commenting about the case uh
this is going to be a good show
well yeah like i said they're saying a
lot of people were saying i don't think
he made it either and the other people
were going yeah you know the
the money never showed up and that's one
of the main things
other people were like well could he
have made it and say yeah he could have
made well yeah because other people
did yeah he could have made he didn't
though which we'll get into because
there were a lot of copycats after he
did it and they
made it they got caught but they didn't
die um
but yeah so definitely like i said and
we'll talk we'll talk about the copycat
stuff we'll talk about all the different
suspects we'll talk about all this kind
of
[ __ ] um but yeah this i love kind of
heists and i love
doing shows i mean i love the true crime
shows
but i think i mentioned this before it's
like i feel
less bad about making jokes on a show
like this
rather than you know the one we did
before about like texas killing fields
where like people got murdered and [ __ ]
i mean this one nobody died except for
possibly
d.b cooper himself and he was a criminal
so no one's all that sad
so it's just like a really interesting
mystery and like i said everybody has
their own theories and their own
theories about what happened to them and
like who the suspects weren't [ __ ] like
that they're all jumping ahead talking
about the damn buried money
these nests don't worry about that
buried money man we'll get to it in a
minute
that buried money was always iffy
yeah i mean like i said we'll get into
that because
that well that's the thing i think
that's the thing that makes this case so
fascinating is that
every single piece of evidence could
totally go either way
you know what i mean there's like no
definitive
yeah this happened or yeah that happened
it's always like well it could be this
could be that that's why they've never
[ __ ] found the dude and they never
found out what happened
finding some of the money confirms to me
that that motherfucker's dead
yeah he was alive he would have took a
bit of money with him although there's
some weird [ __ ] about
when the money was found and when it was
probably deposited there
that maybe yeah well that doesn't
necessarily mean that he put it there
somebody else could have found it and
put it there
i don't know but we're getting ahead of
it um the real seth says i know nothing
about this dude okay well maybe maybe
some people don't like i said it was a
long time ago
this is a good case yeah this is really
fascinating now even though okay this is
crazy to me and i didn't actually even
know this until recently
the dudes the dude did not check in
under d.b cooper he actually checked in
under dan cooper
the only reason that everybody knows him
as db cooper
nowadays is because one of the first
after it happened
one of the first suspects that they that
the fbi
picked up and looked into and then
dismissed because he didn't have
anything to do with it
was a dude named db cooper because they
were like hey maybe this dude that was
hijacking the plane like actually used
his real name and this is him
and there was a mix-up in the newspaper
and somebody printed the suspect's name
db cooper
as uh you know in in place of dan cooper
which was actually the name that
the hijacker checked into the plane
under so the dude actually went under
dan cooper not db cooper that was
somewhat elegant dude's name
so uh so yeah this happened over uh
thanksgiving weekend
in 1971 year i was born
um i will say that the case uh this as
of 2016
uh the fbi has suspended the
investigation because they've just kind
of
exhausted all of their leads at this
point and that dude would be dead
yeah and however if he is caught um i'll
go into that in a little while because
normally um the the crimes that he was
charged with would have
you know would have uh you know been
what do you call it
when when you can't be prosecuted for
that anymore
it's uh statute of limitations normally
but because they changed the crimes too
he violated the hobbes act
um you know so now that doesn't have a
statute of limitations so
technically if he came forward and they
figured out that it was really him he
can still be prosecuted for this
even though like he said he's probably
dead and even if he
lived through that he'd probably be
[ __ ] old as [ __ ] right
by now because he was in his 40s they
think in this early 70s
all right yeah he'd be a hundred yeah
and so he'd
yeah he's got to be dead yeah um okay
with the lifestyles of the 70s and he
was he was a product of the 50s and the
60s he was the chainsmoker
yeah and he liked his bourbon those
dudes drank and [ __ ] spoke
hey they ate [ __ ] they ate [ __ ]
steaks
for hors d'oeuvres let me get a steak a
steak
a steak a steak dinner
and um steak dessert with that and then
some mock apple pie yeah
there's a real man back then and
can i also have six or seven martinis
yeah
i'll see you i'll see you at the
and you guys know topless club cup yeah
yeah that's it thank you exactly come
here darling he's playing [ __ ]
bills putting bills in the garage yeah
that can't be anybody
again again that's that's that's that's
yeah that's that's exactly what they
were
and then they keeled over about five
years yeah
they were tired
[Laughter]
that's great yes
[Laughter]
i just feel like db cooper maybe didn't
sound like that
not when he was 40. it was sounded like
that at 50 or 60 though
probably well they all did yeah yeah
sheila asked jenny what are you drinking
tonight i am drinking a creamsicle
or a 50 50 as they call me yeah which is
whipped cream
vodka and orange juice yeah it's like an
ice cream bar
it does it's it's very good it's kind of
sweet but you know
all right so november 24th 1971
this is uh the day before thanksgiving
of that year
so here comes a dude looked like he was
about middle age like i said
early to mid 40s he's uh has a black
briefcase
and he comes up to um the counter
of northwest airlines orient or orient
alliance this is at portland
international airport portland oregon
and back in the old days when you could
just walk up to the [ __ ] counter
buy a ticket and get on the [ __ ]
plane can't do that [ __ ] anymore
so he says he's dan cooper that's the
name that he wrote down on his little
ticket because you had to write it by
hand by then
uh used cash to purchase a one-way
ticket i believe it was twenty dollars
because this is 1971.
uh so one-way ticket on flight 305 this
was
a flight to seattle it was a 30-minute
flight
now this particular plane was a boeing
727
he gets on now they are not it's weird
because i've seen
three different uh three different
sources say three different seats
like some of them say it was c15d some
said 18e some said 18c i don't know
but anyway it was towards the back of
the plane
now later on uh
the flight crew who spent quite a lot of
time with him as you will
discover described him as
uh as i said being about in his mid-40s
uh they said he was very quiet very
well-mannered very well-behaved
they said he had a business suit on uh
white shirt black tie
now why is your thing baby i don't know
i don't i can't control it
so the flight's waiting to take off and
he orders a bourbon and soda like i said
he liked his burger
now this particular flight there wasn't
a lot of people on it i guess because it
was i don't know it seemed like it'd be
credits it was the day before holiday
but it wasn't they said it was only
about a third full
now it was leaving uh on schedule
a little before three o'clock pacific
standard time
now not too long after the plane took
off
this dude dan this is so funny to me
he hands a note to the flight attendant
who was sitting like right
near him she was kind of sitting in the
jump seat or whatever
her name was uh florence shafter so he
hands her a note
and she thought that it was just some
dude giving
her his phone number so she's just like
oh thanks and she just like stuck in her
purse or a pocket or whatever she didn't
look at it
which is i don't know why that's so
funny to me but that's like really funny
to me
so basically so he sees her do that and
he's just like well [ __ ]
and so then he like leans over and he's
like um hey
might want to look at that guess what i
have a bomb
that's how does that now the note she
finally opens it
and it's a written kind of in all
capital letters
and nobody knows exactly what it said
because i think like dan took it back
before he jumped out the plane
spoiler alert um so nobody knows exactly
what it said but it basically was kind
of like hey i'm hijacking the plane i
want this much money so i have a bomb or
whatever
so florence reads the note and she's
like well [ __ ] me
and then he's like okay come sit next to
me so she came and sat next to him
and then she said that she's like well
can i see the bomb
so he opens up the briefcase and there's
something in there that looks like a
bomb was it a bomb or not i don't know
probably not it was probably a fake bomb
but it looked enough like a bomb that
people would be like oh [ __ ] maybe it's
a bomb that's all you need
yeah it was just like a bunch of things
of dynamite and like some wires
wasn't dynamite it's black flares well
yeah road flares and a clock and a
battery and wires that's all you need
that's yeah that's pretty much it yeah
so he's like look check it out i got a
bomb and she's like well okay well [ __ ]
so then he closes it back up and he says
um that he wants 200 000
in what some people remember him saying
negotiable
american currency which made some people
later on think that maybe he wasn't
american that maybe he was canadian but
i'll get into that in a little bit
he also asked for four parachutes
two primary ones and two reserve ones
and he wanted there to be a fuel truck
standing by
at the seattle airport to refuel the
airplane hold on one second what
he's talking about american currency
yeah
could be i could be what he's talking
about when i was a kid
even in the 80s i remembered some of the
notes were not dollars
remember those some of the notes were
silver certificates
yeah maybe that's what he's talking
about
i don't know because they just gave him
regular money because he asked for it in
twenty dollar bills i'm just saying
maybe he meant he would accept silly
silver certificates
yeah maybe it could be maybe i'm just
saying that because a couple of the
witnesses
said that he said that and he's like if
he was an american he probably would
have just said
money or he wouldn't have specified
american currency
that maybe that many was canadian
because there's a couple other
there's a couple other things that maybe
point to him maybe being canadian might
have just been
him being specific but he might have
just been being yeah like i said
it's just kind of like every other
detail of this case it's like
everything's super nebulous case case
some of you people are too young to know
i know half you [ __ ] have
probably never even seen a down paper
note
because i haven't seen one in [ __ ] 10
years actually everything's electronic
but they used to have things they
weren't really dollars they were called
silver certificates what year were they
from i think the 20s the 30s they were
from the 30s or 40s maybe something like
that
they looked just like a dollar until you
looked real closely at them that they
were slightly different
and it would say like a five dollar
silver certificate
or a twenty dollar silver certificate it
was it was weird
but maybe that's what he was talking
about that he would accept those too
i don't know like i would trade just
like money
i would also accept long john silver's
coupons
or another thing i haven't seen in a
long time remember confederate money
yeah i used to see it in california and
my grandfather was a kid
all the time you used to give it away
for souvenirs
yeah and it wasn't worth anything it's
probably worth something now i don't
know
it's blue well it's worth something to
collectors i'm sure because there's all
kind of people that collect all
historical [ __ ] like that because and
especially something that
is um like paper money that doesn't you
know that disintegrates
after a little while it's just kind of
like why some people
pay like thousands and thousands of
dollars for a movie poster from the
1920s because not a lot of them survived
i remember confederate money was blue
and it was red
yeah i remember i've seen it like i said
my grandfather had them and they were
different sizes because he collected a
lot of stuff yeah like historical kind
of stuff
um okay so at this point florence goes
to the cockpit and says hey there's this
jackpot back there says he has a bomb he
wants all this stuff
so she conveys the information and then
she goes back
to dan's seat and he has put dark
sunglasses on
even though she's already seen what he
looked like good enough that they
got a really good uh sketch of him from
several witnesses
so the pilot of the plane who was named
william scott
uh he calls the airport in seattle and
tells them
what's going on now there were actually
35 other passengers on the airplane
but to you know keep everybody from
freaking out and panicking
they basically they didn't say hey the
plane's being hijacked they said we have
a minor mechanical difficulty we have to
land
uh at seattle airport everything's fine
you know we'll put you on a different
flight
so actually none of the passengers on
board knew that they were being hijacked
you know what i mean because they let
them all get off
so uh so the guy that was like the head
of uh the airline he actually
put together like he got the ransom
money two hundred thousand dollars which
is nice you can just [ __ ] call
the bank and hey we need two hundred
thousand dollars we'll get it right over
there and they did
like they brought it right over there
and they also
it was all like sequential bills right
and they actually took
down because even though this was 1970s
they weren't stupid
they took down all the serial numbers
from every single bill that they gave
him because he specifically asked for
the small bills i think he wanted all
20s
so while this was going on so as i said
the original flight was only supposed to
be 30 minutes
but because it took time to get the fuel
truck there and get the money together
and everything like that uh the airplane
ended up circling around
puget sound for about two hours um and
they
you know got everything together the
parachutes and whatever and you know
they got emergency personnel in some
case something bad happened now one
thing one of the other flight attendants
that kind of interacted with dan cooper
a lot on the plane she said something
interesting
she said that um dan
seemed very familiar with the terrain
while they were flying over it he
actually when they were flying over
tacoma he said hey it looks like tacoma
down there which was correct
he also said he also mentioned that
mccord air force base was only a 20
minute drive away from seattle it's not
anymore but it was then
uh which was also correct now they just
um at this point they said that he kind
of stood out because
there had been plane hijackings before
obviously
but most of the hijackings previously
had not been just for ransom money it
had usually been like political
dissidents or people like they just
were trying to get to cuba they were you
know something like that
so they said that this guy was very he
seemed very calm
um he seemed to have his [ __ ] together
he was very polite
he wasn't you know yelling or like he
was just kind of sitting there
and didn't seem nervous or anything
and um so he had drunk his one bourbon
and soda and then ordered another one
which is is that really why is he going
to jump out of a plane but okay well he
had good tolerance i guess so
he's probably pretty much jacked up on
adrenaline so he probably
yeah i guess so but that's
i'm just going to say if i'm going to
hijack a plane i'm i'm not going to
drink
now just because uh he knew the terrain
and knew where things were
that doesn't mean that he that he had
ever been to that area though
no it doesn't it just means that he had
training
and he knew to plan all this out and he
did what you'd call in the army
a map recon he looked at all the maps of
that area
you know you know and tried to visualize
what it would look like from the air
maybe he flew that route before i don't
know but uh no he
studied the maps and got everything got
um
i guess you could say the lay of the
land before he got there because he of
course he's planning to jump out so he
has to know
how the area is although you know what
though one thing that is really weird to
me
and we'll get into this in a little bit
is that he wanted to go
to mexico city but the pilot was like
well
you know we don't have enough fuel to
fly all the way to mexico city we'd have
to stop somewhere else
and he actually consulted with the crew
as to you know the route they were going
to take
so it wasn't a pre-prescribed route he
didn't have a route in mind
when he got on the plane because they
kind of changed it like while he was
while they were in the air and while he
was so it's really
interesting to me that he didn't he had
good situational awareness he must have
he just yeah he had because he was like
he had to be like thinking on the fly
because they didn't go
you know he didn't seem to have an exact
route planned it's like oh i'm going to
jump out at this point and there's going
to be some somebody waiting for me it's
something like that he has military
experience well everybody yeah
everybody's pretty sure that that was
the case
i mean that's where all that confidence
is coming from
yeah he did a lot of it i believe he was
from the 82nd airborne division
he was used to flying around in
airplanes and jumping out
and [ __ ] doing [ __ ] like that so this
is not an unusual element for him
and he looked at all the maps he knows
what he's doing yeah
well yeah he's not like just something
right and just like when you're planning
a mission
it's the main mission and then there's
like secondary targets and tertiary
targets and backups and
so he has it all planned out in his head
if a doesn't work then we're gonna do b
yeah if b doesn't work then we're going
to do c you know that's that's that's
what he's doing
and he he didn't go into this blind
that's where all that confidence is
coming from
yeah he's already got backup plans in
case things don't fall through
he's got it memorized yeah and he
probably knows pretty much
how long it takes to fly from one place
to the next because he knows how far
everything is
from one another so it's like it's an
awareness of the situation the spatial
awareness
and he knows how fast that plane flies
so well he knew a lot about planes
because like i said
as we'll see in a minute he actually did
give a lot of very specific
like specifications for how he wanted
the plane to fly and [ __ ] like that he's
definitely been in a bunch of aircraft
yeah and he's [ __ ] jumped out of them
before so
yeah like i said every the fbi was
pretty certain that this was somebody
with at least some experience
you're not gonna get some dude that's
never flown or never jumped to do this
well that would be suicidal
i mean i'm not saying db cooper made it
i'm just saying that
you know something always going wrong
yeah you not knowing how to do anything
like that
is gonna that's gonna stack the odds
wildly against you
and i got military guys and some law
enforcement guys in there too that i
know
and uh they're gonna tell you um
most of that [ __ ] high-speed [ __ ] is
experience and confidence
yeah reading about it is not the same as
actually doing it
big difference but a lot of that stuff
is once you've been and been in that
situation a couple of times it kind of
comes naturally
especially if you kind of think about it
for a while
i mean i want to say that even though
obviously he's a criminal
um you gotta admire the dude's balls i
mean
that's a pretty [ __ ] ballsy thing to
be doing yeah is
hijacking a plane and then jumping out
in mid-flight
i'm x hundred first airborne division
first three two seven first five oh six
i
just me and my boys used to fly around
the [ __ ]
helicopters uh ones and uh 60 blackhawks
and the [ __ ] ch-47 chinooks
doors open windows open hanging outside
[ __ ] all that [ __ ]
and after you after a while it's just
yeah yeah it's cool
so yeah you have the confidence and the
comfort it's in your comfort zone
could i hijack a helicopter yeah i can
hijack a helicopter because i've already
flown in one
you know yeah could i fly a helicopter
no
could i learn to fly a helicopter yeah i
could learn to fly especially with the
the these simulators that they have now
yeah i can do it
kind of mix that with [ __ ]
motorcycles and insanity yeah
it's a pretty potent yeah yeah
hovering is the hardest part taking off
and landing in the hover and just
getting the feel yeah i can see that
yeah knowing where what are where all
the instruments are
i'm telling you right now if they try to
[ __ ] it every time i try to fly would do
one of those like flight simulator games
i just like immediately crash right into
the ground the hardest thing about any
kind of flight
so no one should let me fly a plane is
what i'm saying the hardest thing about
any kind of flight
is flying blind just using instruments
that's that's the [ __ ] trick
that would freak me out yeah you can't
see the horizon
i would get just really confused yeah
that would be bad
um so yeah so they got all the uh ransom
money together as i said now they took
like little microfilm pictures of every
single bill
it was ten thousand uh twenty dollar
bills
and uh sheila and i think mentioned in
there and this this is actually true and
i
wanted to mention this but they had
actually been tracking uh serial numbers
ever since the lindbergh
kidnapping which uh we should probably
do a show about that one of these days
too because that's a pretty interesting
case
it's a lot more depressing than this one
though um so
basically so the mccord air force base
actually
offered him the military issue
parachutes but he said no
he wanted civilian ones with manually
operated rip cords
so they ended up getting them from a
local skydiving school
so about 5 24 p.m
pacific standard time uh they tell
cooper
okay we got all your [ __ ] we got the
parachutes we got the money and
everything like that
and then so the plane lands at seattle
tacoma airport at 5 39
p.m now
basically they let he let everybody off
like all the passengers got off like i
said they had no idea that the plane was
being hijacked
um he just basically wanted uh
a few of the you know the pilot
obviously the co-pilot and a couple of
the flight attendants were the only ones
that stayed on the plane
uh and then they had to refuel the plane
now at this point and this is kind of
what i was referring
to earlier he basically says to the
cockpit crew
it's like we want to go to mexico city
he specifically said i want to go the
minimum airspeed possible
without the plane stalling which is
about 100 knots
for that particular plane um and he only
wanted to go as high as 10 000 feet
obviously because he was planning to
jump out he also said
that during the entire flight he wanted
the landing gear
uh kept in the takeoff position
you like you know don't put the uh the
landing gear up
he said he wanted the wing flaps to be
lowered 15 degrees
and the cabin to remain unpressurized
now at this point like i said the um i
think it was the
co-pilot who was uh in the air force
or had been in the air force and during
the korean war and in vietnam
he said oh well okay we can't go all the
way to mexico city we're gonna need to
stop
and make another you know another
refueling stop
so at this point like i said dan cooper
didn't have
a specific route in mind he just wanted
he knew he wanted to get to mexico city
but it seemed like he wasn't super picky
about how to get there and like i said
does it matter that they were going to
mexico city because he was planning on
jumping out
so i don't know but it was really weird
so they're like okay we have to stop and
refuel so they kind of had a big
discussion about that like where are we
going to stop
they finally agreed that they were going
to stop in reno nevada to
refuel now
so basically they're so they're going to
take the take off in the plane
the rear exit door the plane is still
open and its staircase was still
extended uh but the airline
you know the home office of the airline
northwest was kind of like
you know that's against safety
regulations we can't really do that you
know we can't
not supposed to take off with the aft
staircase still hanging out you know
obviously
um but dan cooper was like no no you
know it'll be fine it's safe
um but i guess they kind of argued about
it and then they were like no we're
gonna put the stairs up
um but they're like we'll put it back
down once we're up in the air so that's
what they did
so he did argue with them but he didn't
really get his way i think i i think i
have the idea of what he's doing is he's
trying to
he's trying to confuse his jump zone
that's what he's good with what he's
doing or confuses his land his
his jumps up or his landing zone yeah
he's trying to do he doesn't want the
crew to know when he jumps out
that's what this is that's what's
happening yeah probably although
although they did now which i
didn't know but i think he's trying to
mask yeah
his intent i don't think he wants them
to know where he's jumping out
so they didn't know where to [ __ ]
search yeah see i think he's trying to
i think he's kind of putting him a
little bit on a goose chase maybe we'll
go here maybe we'll go there he doesn't
really care he's just thinking about
where will the plane be pointed once we
leave this this uh
air airport right you know what i mean
once you start shooting down this
azimuth how long should i
wait at the present speed to jump and
where will that be
that's what he's thinking yeah he's
looking out and he's like
there's probably a deserted area i don't
see any lights and then he jumped
that's what he's doing yeah although
you know we'll get into that a little
bit too but it's like i'm trying to
confuse the crew
yeah i guess so yeah so um
another thing that kind of spoke to him
being very familiar with aircrafts and
maybe this
maybe the boeing 727 in particular was
that he seemed to know
how long it should take to refuel it
when they were still on the ground
because it took a little bit longer
because there was some kind of like
mechanical difficulty or whatever and he
was like well you know that shouldn't be
taking that long it should have been
done at this time
so he did actually know how long it
would take to refuel that particular
plane
because he was bitching yeah that's that
military experience though it's
something he found out he's researching
he learned everything about the airline
industry
yeah how long takes refuel that [ __ ]
that's how many guys do it
you know what i mean it's that kind of
stuff well yeah it seemed like he
probably spent
a long time planning this yeah he wanted
to be real familiar with civilian
airlines and their procedures at those
airports
so he planned all this out and you know
he wasn't going to do it once he was
going to do it a couple times that's why
he's doing this
that's why i mean like i said you kind
of have to admire his football you know
what i mean
because that would be an easy gig you
could do that every year once every year
because all those flights that happened
and you could
be a millionaire very quickly well yeah
you'd only have to do it a few times
yeah you'd be the only guy that could do
that
yeah hey i'm the hijacker i'm the dude
you know the right team
send me the [ __ ] parachutes or i'll
blow this [ __ ] up
and jumped out with that fake bomb too
so never know whether or not he had that
a real bomb or not it was a fake bomb
you don't need a real bomb well yeah
it's like much easier because they have
to act like it's real anyway so why
bother building a real bomb and like
risk blowing yourself up
well risk leaving fingerprint leaving
footsteps or footprints behind
like you got to go make or buy explosive
exactly yeah yeah that calls attention
that pings on a radar
exactly you know so
so like i said i think we talked about
this on the collarbone show too it's
like you know if
if you're gonna like do some [ __ ] like
like don't but if you're gonna do some
[ __ ] like this
just make a fake bomb because they have
to act like it's real
because they don't really know because
they're not sure yes that doesn't mean
that they won't kill you though
well yeah they don't know they still
like it well like i said it'll still
kill you
it doesn't matter if it's a real bomb
right oh it's it's just a play bomb it's
a blade
yeah if they can get those crosshairs on
your head that will take that
shot well yeah so well yeah it's not
this is old school [ __ ] anyway man you
want to steal money do [ __ ]
electronically
well yeah nowadays much easier you can
just sit in your basement
you know what you're doing only an idiot
would do something like this now it's
not enough money
yeah it's not really not enough money i
mean
maybe he was just a thrill seeker he was
the daredevil in a different era
it was it's a different era a few
hundred thousand dollars could buy
a lot back then well the two hundred
thousand dollars that he made off with
like i said whether he died or not uh is
over a million dollars
yeah he could buy a lot with yeah and um
it was just like i said a different era
there was there was no other safer way
think about it yeah bankroll bank
robbery would be even more dangerous
because you're on the ground
yeah getting away from there is [ __ ]
difficult well yeah what are you gonna
do [ __ ] teleport
yeah like you gotta get in the car or
you gotta get on a bike or something and
they're going to [ __ ] catch you
so he's doing this heist from a
commanding position which is you know
[ __ ] 30 000
feet you know what i mean [ __ ] over a
deserted area
without any ability for a quick and
enforcement and then their ability to
detect you
yeah yeah he's doing it it's a good idea
he didn't make it though i'm pretty sure
he did it
i mean like i said we'll talk about
there were some too much [ __ ] there was
a bunch of copycats like afterward
yeah too much can go wrong that's the
problem and all those people did make it
but they got caught yeah like later on
there's always a chance that something
can go wrong well and
you know something like this where
there's so many factors where it could
go wrong
so okay so when the plane uh took off
again as i said there were only uh five
people on board it was cooper and uh
you know the pilot the co-pilot and two
other crew members um
also the nearby mccord air force base
uh sent up two uh fighter
planes uh you know scrambled and they
were following
the airliner one above it and one below
it watching the dude
man is in there saying i have no life
i've been a hermit for 10 months
i have nothing to do on a friday night
and i live in las vegas
amanda young woman like yourself living
in las vegas can make
find a way to put never mind what are
you doing pokey people
hi sweetie her little ears popping the
chair
yeah yeah man if i can you know um
living in vegas i'll tell you what girl
you are literally sitting on a gold mine
oh jesus
i will put you up there in my stables
well i mean if you i feel like if you
don't like to gamble if you don't like
to yeah
there's not really a lot of stuff to do
in vegas you know what i'm saying i
don't know i've never done no there's a
lot of trouble to get to
well i know that you know yeah i'm
saying that's not what you're like
so uh so yeah so there were actually two
uh fighter planes kind of trailing
the airline to make sure nothing bad
happened although the visibility was
uh not so great so basically okay so
cooper
tells one of the flight attendants uh
you know go into the
cockpit and just stay in there with the
door closed so he wanted to like do some
[ __ ] in the plane all the
crew members were supposed to stay in
the cockpit she's trying to go off and
not
uh okay and not watch what he was doing
so while she was doing that uh
dan cooper right around eight o'clock
p.m on that night
um it looked like he was like kind of
tying something around his waist
and then uh in the cockpit this little
red warning light flashed
and that was the light that signified
that the uh
that the stairs and the back the air
stairs
in the back of the plane had been
activated
um at this point they got on the
intercom and they asked him hey you need
any help back there what's going on back
there and he's like no
everything's fine that's pretty much all
he said and then a couple
seconds after that uh everyone in the
crew noticed a very it was a very
noticeable
uh change in air pressure so they
assumed that the app door was open
which meant that he had jumped out
now right around 8 13 pm uh
the aircraft crew reported that the tail
section
uh kind of went upward a little bit
enough that
the crew noticed it um and actually it
was severe enough that they actually
kind of had to
you know manually kind of bring the ship
back down so
as i said they they knew that so it must
have been sometime between 8 8
and 8 15 p.m that he jumped out like
they actually felt him jump out and
well and it crashed
yeah it sure did crashed yeah
[ __ ] lost connection